what is your opinion on the vaccine i have
no opinion i'll tell you what the church's
official position is you must make an individual
choice based on praying to god for guidance
following the health laws the counselors of ellen
white and then making your individual decision
that's the position of the church and i am no
position to go against the church because i
see nothing sinful about that counsel make your
individual decision remember psalm 32 verse 8
i will instruct thee and teach thee in the way
which thou shalt go psalm 25 verse 4 show me
thy ways o lord teach me thy paths james 1
verse 5 if any of you lack wisdom let him
ask of god that given to all men liberally
jeremiah 33 3 call unto me and i will answer
thee and show the great and mighty things which
thou knowest ask god should i take the vaccine
he will convict you one way or the
other because your body belongs to him
you